the Joe Rogan experience it was a really
bad stoppage this past weekend in the
UFC really bad really bad that gets so
much controversy huh but this one was a
bad one was the worst stoppage I've ever
seen there was this guy will pull up the
you could find it in the UFC's I've got
to remember how to say this guy's name
what did he claim he stopped the fight
well the referee I don't want to call
the referee out is no need to everybody
knows what it is um he's a nice guy he
[ __ ] up referees [ __ ] up sometimes he
thought the guy was hurt and he wasn't
hurt he was faking it okay so the Mago
Med uncle I've I think that's how you
say it and I forget I say coup de bellas
first day I would think it's Eon I think
it's Eon kuzava yong-seok Udo Bell was
playing possum if you watch the video
you can see the video it looks like he's
playing possum see he's pretending these
hurt see he got hit for sure but look
how he's wobbling his head back and
forth he's trying to sucker him in for
that right hand rise trying to pretend
that he's hurt and then throw that right
hand the referee stops the fight while
he's throwing punches yeah look at him
as soon as the referee stops to fight
he's like I'm fine what the [ __ ] are you
doing that's not a guy who's rocked if
you watch it again you can see that he
definitely is getting hit but you can
also see that like when he like that
that's fake that that's wobbly with the
head well cause he feels a make he's
trying to lure the guy into thinking
that he's so hurt that he can't control
himself and he's trying to throw
haymakers but he's also definitely
getting hit too so I could see how the
referee fell for it but you got to let
guys fight you got to let guys fight and
sometimes referees in the interest of
the fighter trying to save a guy from
damage they step in and they make a
mistake that's an easy mistake to make
because it is a really bad stoppage
but because the fact that he was faking
like you was hurt but he wasn't faking
like he was hurt enough to stop a fight
now it's like it when a guy's swinging
back with big wild haymakers he can win
at any time Yeah right I mean we've seen
that [ __ ] bridle I mean there's been
many many fights where you see a guy
a fight that he's getting dominated
because he catches the guy who gets
overzealous and tries to finish him off
that's what we got robbed of the referee
[ __ ] up or the you know the the
referee I mean he [ __ ] up but he also
was a little bit tricked by this guy's
trying to lure this guy in by pretending
and then exploding right he didn't look
like even if the guy was really that
rocked it wasn't enough to stop the
fight that guy was throwing back he was
defending himself he was moving back
with his hands out but he's trying to
fight you know the fight just doesn't
end when someone gets hit right like no
the fight ends when you can't protect
yourself anymore when it was defenseless
yeah very different it was very
dangerous still that was a bummer to
watch that's that's real well you feel
bad for the guy who [ __ ] up a little
bit not a you know the referees not a
bad guy he just [ __ ] up and then the
fighter
you gotta think that guy trained for
months for that moment and he's trying
to sucker this guy in I mean maybe he's
got this thing that he does is he Russia
tens like he's hurt I don't know where
coup de bellas from is that rest gonna
die number if he's Russian that
represent a month it's I don't think
it's a corruption thing I think that's
just a mistake yeah it's [ __ ] hard
man dov'è malulu it's a [ __ ] hard job
man that's me you're in there these
dudes are throwing their [ __ ] knees
in each other's faces and I kick each
other and it's just you yeah the only
that's the other thing other sports have
many refs you're the only one did and
you're on when do I stop all right stop
it [ __ ] that yeah yeah the pressure
isn't saying so many other sports can
rely on other referees to go oh [ __ ] I
think we [ __ ] up where I [ __ ] up
this one is like it's this dude that was
a bad call yeah that was a bad call but
it happens it's our gig xanthine it's a
tough gig to do
[Applause]